you can hate Jake Paul you know I don't  like the guy but I won't shy away from  talking about like his story as a  fighter it's like I don't have an issue  acknowledging like yeah he's getting  better he's on track to be good I'm  curious to see where he lands whatever  but I will say the people that go maybe  just he's just beating up old guys for  money okay dude half of you dudes have  had private conversation with your boys  where you're like how much to suck a  dick and some of you have been like  [ __ ] I'll suck a dick for 100 grand  right now so you you beat the [ __ ] out  of an old guy for like five mil okay I  don't want to hear it there's definitely  a number yeah for sure you got a number  yeah just say you don't like him yeah  just I just you just don't like him  that's fine